Now Ross, there's a huge TV event this weekend,
and some are even calling it a second Super Bowl.
And we talked about it when it was first announced.
This Sunday, Oprah sits down for a two hour, wow.
Two hour power interview
with Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
and it's their first high-profile interview
since moving to the U.S.
And stepping back from their Royal post
and CBS posted a sneak peek.
Let's take a look.
Okay.
You know, for me, I'm just really relieved
and happy to be sitting here,
talking to you with my wife by my side.
Because I can't begin to imagine
what it must've been like for her
going through this process by herself, all those years ago.
Because it has been unbelievably tough for the two of us
but at least we have each other.
Okay, I am so over the moon, I cannot wait for this.
Are you gonna be camped out in front of your TV for this?
I really will be appointment television for this.
I'm gonna set out a whole Harry Meghan crudités,
I'm gonna make Buckingham roll ups, I don't know.
I'm just gonna go all out.
Oprah is the perfect person for them to sit down with.
Perfect.
And what do you want?
Like where do you want Oprah to go with this interview?
I think I would very much appreciate it
to be half a celebration of
the freedom that they fought for.
So Buckingham rolls and all the cute accoutrements
to make it feel celebratory because I think there's been
so much pain and controversy that I would like to see
a little bit of levity and humanity,
but I also wonder if it will ever be pressed upon
about just the dangers of our society
and what they can lead to.
And for that to sink in at some point.
So maybe this will be another stepping stone to that.
And we rarely get insight, right? Into that family.
So I wanna know how Harry and William are,
I wanna know how Meghan and Kate are.
I wanna know what the queen puts out for a breakfast buffet.
I wanna know everything.
Well, be sure to watch on CBS this Sunday
at 8:00 PM Eastern.
Yeah and if Royals aren't your thing,
I don't know who you are,
but maybe you'll tune into the critic's
choice awards instead.
They're happening on Sunday night on The CW,
and Variety reports that yet again, "Mank"
"Mank" that film on Netflix, the black and white one,
is out front with 12 nominations.
"Minari" is in second with 10
and Netflix, they have made history,
with four best picture nominations.
"Da 5 Bloods" by Spike Lee,
"Ma Rainey's Black Bottom" by George C. Wolfe,
"Mank" that David Fincher directed
and "The Trial of The Chicago 7".
Some good movies all available for you to watch
right now on Netflix, before the big awards.
And for those in it just for the fashion,
the Critics' Choice always brings some good looks
because the pressure is not really on
like it is for the Oscars so people have a little fun.
Last year, remember Zendaya?
She was nominated for "Euphoria".
Look at, oh, my God, right?
I will never forget this look, I loved it so much.
I've never seen anything like it.
Beyond.
Florence Pugh, was nominated for "Little Women" last year.
She came in wearing this, which was gorgeous.
She is a knockout.
Billy Porter for "Pose"
who always brings it (laughs) on the red carpet, yeah.
I mean, he's like a combo
of so many things right there.
It's really interesting.
Because it's fun, you know,
like I said the pressure is off Saoirse Ronan.
Oh, please!
Could I ever find a dress that looks like that?
I just have to say what you're wearing today
is a little that.
Oh my goodness! You know what?
We might have to do it side by side.
Well, at least, you know, I'm being honest when
I say I like it cause I'm wearing like the other
more casual wearable version.
Here we go. Ready?
Yes.
Yeah, clearly I'm into this.
And look now Drew, you're inspiring me.
Look at this. Look look.
Hi! (chuckles)
Rossy!
It's starts with her, to you to me.
Oh like, I think you might need to support that
for the rest of the segment.
Okay it's on, it's on with tape so we'll see if it stays.
A couple more looks from last year,
is Cynthia Erivo for "Harriet."
Look at this look, which I just, Oh my gosh.
I'm so in love with her and her stylist
they always bring it.
They're the ones always to watch.
And Kristen bell from last year as well.
Look at that. That color is so good.
It's like a highlighter Citron situation.
She inspires me in this look to bring it.
She looks great.
Yeah.
All right Drew, you know, we're talking about
spring cleaning, since it's spring, we got our flowers on.
I know you already started taking on your coat closet.
Yes.
You posted something on Instagram
that gave me a major anxiety.
Yes.
Yeah, this freaked me out when I was looking at it.
Yep. And I have to fit all that
in this like narrow, you know, our coat closet is,
you know, only about a foot, I don't know, two feet wide.
And so I basically took everything out to put it back in,
in a different, less chaotic way.
You have a lot of stuff, allright?
And now's the time people are spring cleaning
getting it all together.
And here's some tips for you.
Southern living reports that Bissell has released
a spring cleaning guide, Drew,
to organize your cleaning spree.
So check this out.
It breaks tasks into manageable chunks.
You can clean a chunk, cross out a chunk,
clean a chunk, cross out a chunk.
You can visually see your slow and steady progress
up spring cleaning mountain,
because then it is like a mountain.
You are climbing.
When you look at that pile and go, what do you do?
So here's a way they say that can help you
sort of (snaps) clean it up.
This turns me on.
I don't know how else to say it.
I am hot to try.
I'm going to get on this calendar
because it talks about cleaning like drapes
and dog toys and the inside of your washer,
all these things that we just don't even think about.
So, I think this is sexy and unique and approachable.
I'm going to get you outside of the box
from your own routine.
I am in.
I love that you think this is sexy. You are so weird.
I am.
Yeah.
Can I ask you, are you neat and tidy?
Totally neat and tidy.
Yeah, I can't handle a mess.
That's why your IG was driving me crazy, yeah.
And really what this list says at the end of the day.
I could just break it down, it start with one thing,
one at a time.
When you're looking at that pile,
pick one thing and then onto the next and onto the next.
So you don't want a mountain Ross.
You want a tiny little mole hill.
I'm fine with a mole hill, thank you.
I am the Everest of mess, all right.
(Ross laughs)
(upbeat music)